Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at that
time the MI6 used s*m*n as invisible ink…
The British Secret Intelligence Service, better
known to the world as MI6 (Military Intelligence,
Section 6), is, rather oddly for a supposedly
secretive agency, one of the better known
intelligence services in the world.
While the work MI6 does today is top-secret,
thanks to the wonders of the Freedom of Information
Act, we’re able to peer into the mysterious
agency’s beginnings and marvel at all the
humourous things they did in their early days
in the name of protecting British interests-
like the time they told agents to use their
own s*m*n as ink when sending secret messages.
We should probably mention at this point that
the head of the agency telling the agents
to do this was the aptly named Mansfield Smith-Cumming...
We can’t make this stuff up.
The history of MI6 can be traced back to 1909
where a precursor to the agency was set up
by the British government to investigate German
citizens who were increasingly being accused
of being spies by the paranoid public.
(In fact, there was a growing sentiment that
pretty much all German born individuals in
Britain were spies.)
As mentioned, the head of this fledgling agency,
then known as the Secret Service Bureau, was
one Mansfield Smith-Cumming, a legendary figure
in British military history, famed as much
for his eccentricities as he was for his accomplishments
as the first director of MI6.
Smith-Cumming, or "C" as he was affectionately
known during his tenure as director (originally
standing for "Cumming", rather than "Chief"
as it does today when referring to an MI6
director), was formerly a royal navy captain
who suffered from severe seasickness...
As you might imagine, this ultimately resulted
in him being deemed unfit for service.
As to why he was chosen to head up the new
spy agency, this seems to have been primarily
due to his impressive intelligence gathering
background.
For instance, in his post-naval captain career,
he was once tasked with gathering certain
information while posing as a German businessman
in Germany and the Balkans.
Why's that impressive?
He reportedly succeeded in his mission despite
not being able to speak a word of German.
As to the spy organisation he led, in the
beginning they were less James Bond and more
a sort of Monty Python caricature of spying;
bumbling buffoonery and gathering false intelligence
and presenting it as fact become a staple
of MI6.
For example, prior to World War 1, C's foremost
weapons expert disappeared for a time while
abroad.
Perhaps captured by some foreign power?
Nope- the agent couldn’t find anyone who
could give him directions in English and ultimately
became thoroughly lost.
On another occasion, C was reportedly fooled
by a phony document stating that German spies
had extra rows of teeth.
He also once spent a considerable amount of
the Agency’s scant resources searching Britain
for a hidden cache of German weapons that
simply didn’t exist.
One notable "victory" C achieved in these
early days was a comprehensive file he compiled
on Zeppelins.
Apparently none of his superiors realised
that all the information was publicly available
at the time.
All C did was have it translated from German
to English; this report was hailed as a major
victory for the British intelligence agency.
When the First World War broke out, the Secret
Service Bureau was overhauled and rebranded
as MI6, not that anyone publicly knew.
At this time, the British Government still
denied that it existed.
As you might imagine, the agency being a secret
made it hard to get good applicants.
When potential new agents were identified,
C had a novel way of interviewing them without
giving away that he worked for a shadowy government
agency.
In short, a key facet of the selection process
was the gold monocled director suddenly stabbing
himself in the leg.
You see, in 1914 C lost his leg during a traffic
collision in France which tragically claimed
the life of his son.
While hospital reports indicate that his leg
was amputated the day after the accident,
C himself liked to claim that he cut it off
himself with a pen-knife in order to be able
to get to his dying son.
At other times, he'd say he lost it in a fight
with a wild animal.
After the accident, C mostly got around with
the aid of a wooden leg and a sword (hidden
inside of a cane).
In any event, C would interview potential
agents pretending he worked for a more mundane
facet of the government.
With the process moving along at a slothful
pace, in true Monty Python-skit fashion, without
warning, he'd suddenly violently stab himself
in his covered wooden leg mid-conversation.
If the person flinched, the interview was
over and the individual was asked to leave.
(Akin to the old "two for flinching tactic"...)
The flinchers clearly weren't secret agent
material.
If they kept their composure, he’d reveal
the true nature of the interview.
(C apparently found the reactions he sometimes
got from doing this so amusing that he reportedly
also used to do it during regular state meetings.)
So where does s*m*n come into this?
Well, like any respectable spymaster, C was
very interested in covert communication- in
particular invisible ink.
However, a key problem was that most fluids
that could function as an invisible ink and
the methods that could be used to reveal them
were widely known.
To solve the problem, in 1915 C approached
scientists at London University and tasked
them with discovering a new type of invisible
ink.
According to C’s own diaries, though, s*m*n’s
use as an invisible ink wasn’t discovered
by anyone at the university.
Instead, one of his agents, whose name is
omitted from his diary for obvious reasons,
made the breakthrough.
After investigation, it really did turn out
that, along with being a substance readily
available to any male agent, when exposed
to the usual detection methods of the time,
such as iodine vapour, letters penned with
s*m*n as ink refused to surrender their contents.
C was apparently thrilled to learn of this
use for s*m*n, allegedly quipping that “now
every man has his own stylo”.
An altered version "every man his own stylo"
was adopted by the agents as their motto for
a time.
Despite making a discovery that allowed British
agents to communicate covertly, the agent
who discovered this was so teased by other
agents after the fact that he had to be moved
to a different department.
Understandably, the use of s*m*n to pen secret
messages led to some hilarious exchanges,
such as one between an agent in Copenhagen
called Major Holme and C’s subordinate,
Frank Stagg.
In the message, Stagg was forced to tell Holme
that “a fresh operation was necessary for
each letter” after people in his office
began complaining that all Holme's letters
stank.
You see, Major Holme had decided to stock
up a large supply of "ink" in an inkwell so
he didn't need to do what was necessary to
get fresh "ink" every time he wanted to send
a secret letter.
So to sum up, during the First World War,
actual British spies had a meeting with a
one-legged, gold-monocled, cane-sword carrying
guy called Captain Cumming, during which he
enthusiastically told them they needed to
start using their own s*m*n as an invisible
ink- requiring that anytime they needed to
send a secret message, they had to masturbate
immediately before doing so...
Bonus Facts:
• According to Ian Flemming, the original
author of the James Bond series, the eccentric
quartermaster, M, is based on Mansfield-Cumming.
(Incidentally, Flemming also wrote Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang.)
Also, the name “James Bond” is actually
that of an ornithologist.
Originally, Fleming wanted James bond to be
a boring, ordinary man who happened to experience
some extraordinary things.
He knew about an ornithologist named James
Bond from Bond’s book, Birds of the West
Indies, which he had read in his youth and
thought the author’s name was one of the
most boring names he’d ever heard.
Thanks to Flemming, the boring name soon became
rather exciting.
Mrs. Ornithologist Bond actually sent Fleming
a letter thanking him for using the name.
So I hoped you enjoyed this video, if you
did please do give it a like below and consider
sharing it with anyone you think might also
enjoy it.
It really helps us out a lot.
And do check out our archives, we’ve got
almost 700 videos now so you’re sure to
find something you find interesting.
Thanks for watching.